storm of comets have come in for this
one upgrade red band trailer Lily one
nails Blum house new feature film red
band you know this will perform well on
YouTube they love grisly violence and
all that and hey revolver says he has a
problem my headphones I could [ __ ] my
boy in this movie look at Marshall green
whoa
it's the thing for guys murdered a
[Music]
computer chip that it's potential to
change everything
it's
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
Leigh Whannell really stepping up his
game
Leigh Whannell has upgraded his
directing all right I know I know it's
cut my teeth on that insidious thing
right here hear that like he's ever
gotta change wan inspirations you can
see in this end of directional watch it
was like flipping cha yeah there's like
hothead a lot with James Wan over the
years you could feel that inspiration
right this is a confident trailer this
this is the better version of the tuxedo
a whole lot more I mean it's got I love
when they can blend like low-five future
where it's like you know kind of sci-fi
you know there's cool cars these sort of
futuristic houses and stuff but it still
looks kind of grimy at the same time
yeah it's like a semi you know I'm sure
it's gonna be like hi miss acceptance I
miss r-rated sci-fi we don't get enough
of that anymore I mean we do but not on
like this high concept like oh this
could bring in an audience this kind of
yeah this is like technological
advancements that I'm sure is like very
high concept for what it is but you're
still like maybe the future that yeah
you know like fix people's you know
paralysis with some kind of chip or
nanotech cuz the first 30 45 seconds I
was like okay just generic revenge movie
that's what I was the vibe I was getting
his wives and families had killed a lot
of movies and then and then when the
switch started happening permission
granted
I love the fighting style because he's
like I don't know
it tells I use like stay down man he's
like no I'm not even in control of this
there was just some brutal ass dance
though like when he takes the knife
this is categorized as an action horror
sci-fi and I feel oh yeah baby I feel
all three I mean it doesn't look like
it's gonna be like scary horror but I'll
have the element swords Leigh Whannell
so you expect that him dealing with the
sci-fi territory looks cool yeah this
looks like my kind of movie right here I
just want this to be a fun high-octane
action thriller and I feel like it's
gonna give me exactly that oh this is
easily my list like most anticipated
easily just went up down that was that
was freaking brutal and awesome thank
you guys for blowing up our comic box
with this trailer I'm used to seeing him
be more reserved just to watch him go
all out like I'm also curious if -
whether he like really trained for this
yeah obviously did I mean you've seen
the fight scenes you could tell it's
really him doing it alright well upgrade
upgrade it all around from behind the
scenes in front of the camera that looks
sweet properly you ever see this props
subscribe to the reject nation people
and click that notification bell we had
to click Blum houses that's why we
didn't know about it and you could check
us out on patreon full-length reactions
to TV shows watch along as well as
weekly Q&A is would love to have you
become a patron of Jack thank you again
for recommending this